star trek picard meets deep space nine
in the first episode of season two and
that's not the only easter egg buried in
this reference heavy show
the premiere episode of picard season
two opens with starfleet officers
scurrying through the corridors in the
middle of what appears to be a battle
aboard a starship arriving on the bridge
things aren't looking good as an unseen
villain is tapping into the ship's
systems and appears to be gaining
control unable to overpower the enemy
picard commands the ship's computer to
activate the auto-destruct sequence we
later learn the enemy is the borg and
long time fans will note this isn't the
first time that picard has had to order
self-destruct due to a borg invasion it
is however a major change from his
previous behavior and shows he's learned
a lesson from a certain former klingon
security chief in the 1996 film star
trek first contact the borg had
infiltrated the enterprise and had
controlled more than half the ship
picard's trusted officer and friend
lieutenant commander wharf recommended
they self-destruct the ship in order to
prevent its total takeover picard
adamantly refused to destroy it and it
wasn't until he got a lecture from lily
that he relented and set the ship to
self-destruct this time it seems picard
is much quicker to respond having
learned that when the borg take over
sometimes it's best to activate the
ship's auto destruct system right away
as many eagle-dyed viewers noticed in
the first teaser for the new season a
major piece of deep space nine lore
appeared prominently on the table in
picard's library it appeared that the
former enterprise captain an avid
archaeologist was studying the reckoning
tablet which originally made its first
and only appearance in star trek deep
space nine
i see you recognize it in the episode
the reckoning the tablet was smashed to
pieces by captain cisco after he
received a vision in doing so he
released the villainous parades that
were locked in a centuries-long war with
the bajoran prophets many wondered if
the appearance of the tablet was an
easter egg just for trailers perhaps as
a simple reference to star trek deep
space nine but the tablet does indeed
appear in the opening episode of picard
season two as picard and laris speak in
his library it appears on the table
between them in the center of the screen
and it is still in pieces there's a
viewing glass above it which suggests
picard has indeed been studying it given
its prominence in the scene we wonder if
it's more than just an easter egg and
perhaps a hint of more to come
as the first episode transitions to
picard's speech at starfleet academy we
see picard in his new role as chancellor
of the academy standing before a group
of incoming cadets behind him is a
series of flags presumably a federation
member worlds that's notable because
there's a number of flags from worlds
who weren't members of the federation
during the next generation while we do
see flags for the tellerites and vulcans
who were founding members we see a
klingon flag as well long-time allies of
the federation since at least the days
of tng it seems they could now be full
members of the ufp we also see the
bajoran flag indicating that bajor may
have finally gained membership following
deep space nine but the most curious
flag is the ferengi flag though
ferenganar was on its way to change with
the appointment of the less greed
focused rom as their grand nagis at the
end of deep space nine it's curious that
they'd become federation members so
quickly a new foreigner needs a new kind
of [ __ ] kinder gentler [ __ ] and
that's you my boy if these aren't the
flags of federation members then it's
possible these are simply flags of
worlds from which starfleet academy has
found cadets meaning the ferengi flag is
a reference to the character nog the
young ferengi who attended the academy
and served aboard the defiant on deep
space nine
during his speech picard is proud to
introduce his friend elenor as the first
fully romulan entrant into starfleet
academy this indicates that at some
point prior to the events of the episode
the academy had admitted other cadets
with at least partial romulan ancestry
it's notable also because there has been
at least one starfleet officer that
we've seen whose bloodline could be
traced to romulans a crewman named simon
tarsus from the next generation episode
the drum head tarsus was investigated
for his possible role in sabotaging the
enterprise but his real crime was lying
about his parentage by claiming he was
part vulcan rather than romulan the
paternal grandfather of whom you speak
was not a vulcan but it was in fact a
romulan
that it is romulan blood you carry
ultimately tarsus did not even attend
the academy and chose to enlist instead
nevertheless it was heavily implied that
there was great controversy surrounding
officers who carried the blood of a
federation enemy it remains to be seen
if this will be an issue for elnor who
vocalizes his concerns about fitting in
at the academy due to his race though
picard's gift a book written by spock
should help
the picard season 2 premiere gives us a
surprising glimpse into the childhood of
john luke picard and hints that
something terrible may have happened to
his mother when he was young but it's
his mother's inspiring words to the
young picard as he looked up into the
night sky that are the source of
character drama in this episode in
flashbacks we see how yvette picard
nurtured her son's love of the stars
offering to build him an observatory of
sorts on the family estate we know from
the tng episode family that picard's
father and brother both decried his
choice to enter starfleet so it seems a
fitting revelation that it was his
mother who helped ignite his exploratory
spirit but in his speech to the academy
picard chooses to quote his mother with
a phrase that clearly stuck with him all
of his life let's see what's out there
it's an inspiring moment and one that
affected picard greatly and die hard
trekkies will remember this line for its
appearance in the tng premiere episode
encounter at farpoint let's see what's
out there
[Music]
engage
back at the academy cadets await their
first assignments with an officer
calling out names and ships for them to
report to one cadet is sent to the
hikaru sulu clearly named for the
helmsman of the original uss enterprise
originally played by george takei in
star trek generations we met sulu's
daughter who helmed the enterprise bee
and it's clear from this new starship
that her father's name has carried a
powerful legacy even into the 25th
century other ships include the
excelsior captained by rafi where
eleanor is assigned and the uss grissom
the original excelsior was captained by
sulu himself in star trek vi the
undiscovered country while it wouldn't
be unprecedented if eleanor's ship were
the same excelsior it's most likely a
newer ship with the same name the
grissom meanwhile though not seen was
the name of the science vessel that
carried lieutenant savic and david
marcus to the genesis planet in star
trek iii the search for spock admiral
picard also mentions to rafi his
intention to make some modifications to
the kobayashi meru test which is
designed to evaluate an officer's
decision-making skills in a no-win
situation this test has been seen or
referenced several times most famously
in star trek ii the wrath of khan but
again in jj abram's star trek reboot
when picard visits his old friend gainen
who is now attending a bar in los
angeles he goes to an address that will
make fans of the next generation smile
10 forward street fans will recall the
location of guidance bar on the
enterprise as 10 forward but that's
hardly the only easter egg behind the
bar we see bottles of cardassian canar
from deep space nine also on the wall is
designed for our conus lager first seen
in star trek iii the search for spock
when the two sit down for a drink she
offers up some options but selects a
bottle of soari and brandy a classic
trek ale seen many times throughout the
franchise here she refers to it as hooch
seeming to reveal the drink is something
less than a classy top shelf spirit
when they first meet picard notes that
guidance people the alloryans age slowly
and she tells him that aging is
something that happens only if we choose
to and that she has chosen to for the
benefit of humans who dislike being
reminded of their own mortality this
helps explain to audiences why the
centuries-old gainen played by whoopi
goldberg looks 20 years older than the
last time we saw her in star trek
nemesis she then makes a few clever nods
to classic tng episodes referencing the
times that they stood side by side to
face a new galactic threat like they did
with the borg in the episode cue who she
also references the events of
yesterday's enterprise when she recalls
the time that they jumped universes
together but picard hasn't come to
reminisce and is instead looking for
some advice regarding his love life
picard insists that he has loved before
and quite deeply to which geinan
responds always with those who would
only be temporary it's true that picard
has had a handful of dalliances in trek
and the most obvious candidate is
renegade archaeologist bosh whom he met
in captain's holiday hupacard clearly
held a deep and passionate attraction
towards but as gainan said vosh was
never a good match because she was
always on the move and picard's first
love was starfleet their most haunting
exchange is when she tells picard that
he should know better than most that
there are worse things than being dead
this is a clear reference to his
previous assimilation by the borg when
they stole his body and mind and used
him as an instrument of destruction
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]